Hallo, guten Tag. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özbole. Ich bin als Arzt-Standarzt auf
dieser Station tätig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstanden oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie mich bitte etwas wissen.
Alles in Ordnung? Ja, natürlich. Als erstes benötige ich eine persönliche Daten und dann können wir weiterfahren.
Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Zara Belauswita. Können Sie bitte Vor- und Nachnamen langsam
buchstabieren? Ja, S-A-R-A-H. Mein Nachname buchstabiert sich B-L-A-U-Z-V-I-T-E-R.
Zara Belauswita. Wie? Wie will her? Nach dem Set V. Ja. Okay. V-I-T-T-O-D-O-R-E-V-E-M-L-R-V-V-S-A.
Okay. Okay. Belauswita. Okay. Vielen Dank für die Information. Und wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
55 Jahre alt. Ja. Und wie viel wiegen Sie? Ich wiege 85,3 Kilo. 85,3. Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,63 Meter groß.
1,63 Meter groß. Okay. Alles gut. Frau Belauswita, was für Sie ist für uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Also ehrlich gesagt fühle ich mich seit Wochen total müde. Ich bin einfach erschöpft und abgeschlagen.
Und morgens habe ich fast jeden Tag Kopfschmerzen. Ja, ich verstehe. Seit wann haben Sie die Müdigkeit?
Seit drei, vielleicht vier Wochen. Und es wird von Tag zu Tag immer schlimmer. Am Anfang dachte ich es geht wieder vorbei, aber nein.
Wird es immer schlimmer, Tudor? Ja, ja. Wie gesagt wird es von Tag zu Tag immer schlimmer.
Und noch haben Sie gesagt, ein Kopfschmerzen oder? Ja, ich habe auch Kopfschmerzen jeden Tag, fast jeden Tag.
Jeden Tag. Frau Belauswita, schlafen Sie gut oder? Nein, Herr Doktor. Ich kann nicht gut schlafen.
Vielleicht wie viele Stunden pro Nacht? Tatsächlich bin ich im Bett fast acht Stunden, aber ich habe Probleme gut zu schlafen.
Ich kann nicht gut schlafen. Ich muss vier bis fünfmal pro Nacht zur Toilette gehen und mein Mann weckt mich ständig, weil ich wohl schnarche.
Vier bis fünfmal? Ja. Für was? Auf die Toilette. Ich muss auf die Toilette gehen. Deswegen kann ich nicht gut schlafen.
Ja, ich verstehe. Es ist schwierig. In der Nacht mindestens vier bis fünfmal stehen Sie für Wasserhassen.
Haben Sie noch Konzentrationsstörungen? Ja, auch habe ich Konzentrationsstörungen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich Auto fahre, muss ich manchmal für ein paar Sekunden die Augen schließen. Das ist doch gefährlich oder?
Ich kann nicht konzentrieren, sogar zu Autofahren. Ja, natürlich. Das ist sehr gefährlich. Sie haben schon eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen. Das ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema.
Außerdem muss ich auch auf meine Enkelkinder passen. Aber das schaffe ich im Moment gar nicht mehr. Ich bin einfach zu müde.
Ja, ich verstehe. Es ist sehr schwierig, um die Kinder zu kümmern. Aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen. Wir können eine Lösung finden.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Kopfschmerzen. Würden Sie mir einmal Ihren Kopfschmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, bitte schön. Wie lange dauert es? Welche Charaktere?
Es ist eher drückend. So ein Druck im ganzen Kopf. Besonders morgens ist es stärker als tagsüber.
Morgen ist es stärker. Wie beschreiben Sie auf einer Schmerzskala? 1, 0, kein Schmerzen und 10, stärker Schmerzen. Was würden Sie?
Vielleicht 6 morgens. Aber im Laufe des Tages verbessert sich die Schmerzen.
Morgens 6. Ja, mindestens 6. Aber vielleicht Nachmittag oder Abend?
Ja, wie gesagt, im Laufe des Tages verbessert sich die Schmerzen.
Dagegen haben Sie schon Schmerzmittel? Nein, ich versuche damit umzugehen. Ohne Medikamente.
Gibt es eine Auslösung? Oder gibt es etwas verschlimmert?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt. Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Aber haben Sie täglich diese Schmerzen? Ja, fast jeden Tag.
Herr Doktor, wie gesagt, schnarche ich. Und anscheinend sehr laut. Mein Mann schläft inzwischen sogar im anderen Zimmer.
Er sagt, ich höre manchmal auf zu atmen und würge dann im Hals.
Ich habe Angst. Ja, natürlich. Seit wann haben Sie Schmerzen? Was sagt Ihr Mann?
Wie gesagt, diese Beschwerden, Müdigkeit, Konzentration, Störungen und Schnarchen seit 3-4 Wochen.
Vorher haben Sie keine Beschwerden? Nicht so sehr. Natürlich habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Manchmal habe ich mich müde gefühlt, aber nicht so stark.
Früher hat mein Mann nicht darüber Beschwerden. Aber jetzt ist es schwer für uns.
Nicht nur für mich, sondern auch für meinen Mann.
Es ist sehr schwierig für Ihre Beschwerden. Aber vor 4 Wochen hatten Sie keine Beschwerden, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Eigentlich nicht. Aber nicht so sehr.
Alles gut. Bekommen Sie Atemnot, wenn Sie flach liegen?
Herr Doktor, wenn ich auf dem Rücken schlafe, verschlechtern sich diese Beschwerden.
Fragen Sie das? Ja, flach liegen.
Aber Atemnot? Manchmal wache ich richtig auf und schnappe nach Luft.
Ja, in der Nacht. Aber tagsüber habe ich keine Atemnot.
Ihr Mann hat schon gesagt, Sie schnarchen beim Laufen. Und er hat gesagt, noch eine Atemunterbrechung.
Ja, genau.
Kennen Sie, wie lange dauert diese Atemunterbrechung?
Ich weiß nicht, Herr Doktor. Ich denke, dass er nicht gerechnet hat.
Ja, okay, natürlich. Es ist sehr schwierig, das in einem Labor zu führen.
Alles gut. Atmen Sie beim Schlafen durch den Mund oder die Nasen?
Ja, durch den Mund. Ich wache jeden Morgen auf mit einem trockenen Mund.
Ja, trockenen Mund. Jeden Tag? Ja, fast jeden Tag.
Haben Sie noch geschwollene Beine? Was habe ich nie bemerkt?
Keine geschwollene Beine. Tagsüber fühlen Sie sich Atemnot oder?
Wie gesagt habe ich keine Atemnot. Aber ich fühle mich müde.
Immer müde und schläfrig? Ja, schläfrig auch.
Alles gut.
Beim Schlafen, wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie in der letzten vier Wochen?
Ja, zwei Kissen.
Ohne zwei Kissen schlafen Sie gut oder?
Nein, wie gesagt, alle Beschwerden verschlechtern sich ohne Kissen.
Wenn ich auf dem Rücken schlafe.
Alles gut. Und in der letzten Zeit, haben Sie ab oder zugenommen?
Ja, leider. Ich habe in den letzten drei Jahren etwa 20 Kilo zugenommen.
Gestern habe ich mich gewogen. 85,3 Kilo, Herr Doktor. Das ist zu viel.
Ja, ich verstehe. Haben Sie schon eine Diätveränderung oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Alles gut.
Sie haben schon gesagt, in der Nacht vier oder fünf Mal beim Schlafen.
Haben Sie schon etwas Stuttgart-Probleme?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich habe Verstöße.
Seit wann?
Diese Beschwerde habe ich seit Jahren. Ich kann nicht genau sagen, seit wann.
Dagegen haben Sie etwas eingenommen oder?
Nein, ich möchte nicht Medikamente nutzen, anwenden.
Statt Medikamente nehme ich oder kaufe ich im Drogeriemarkt manche pflanzliche Mittel.
Ja, alles gut.
Ok. Beim Wasserlassen in der Nacht, besonders in der Nacht. Wie viel Menge?
Normal Menge, aber die Häufigkeit. Das Problem ist die Häufigkeit des Wasserlassens.
Auch ein brennendes Gefühl oder Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, Gott sei Dank habe ich keine solche Beschwerde.
Alles gut. Haben Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Meinen Sie Bluthochdruck zum Beispiel?
Seit 3 Jahren leide ich an Bluthochdruck, Herr Doktor.
Und ich habe auch erhöhte Blutverfärde.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Seit 3 Jahren Bluthochdruck und seit 5 Jahren Cholesterin Spiegel.
5 Jahre, Cholesterin ein bisschen hoch und gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, ich habe keine andere.
Würden Sie schon mal operieren oder?
Herr Doktor, ich hatte eine OP vor 10 Jahren zur Entfernung der Gallenblase.
Gallenblase, entfernt vor 10 Jahren.
Alles gut. Wissen Sie, wegen einer Stein- oder Blasensündung?
Ja, wegen einer Steinentzündung hat meine Blase entzündet.
Der Arzt hat es so gesagt. Aber ich weiß nicht genau.
Alles gut. War das komplikationlos?
Nein, das war in Ordnung. Alles war in Ordnung.
Welche Medikamente haben Sie eingebunden?
Herr Doktor, ich nehme Balzartan und Lipuzet auch morgens.
Balzartan 80 mg und Lipuzet 10 mg, 20 mg.
Lipuzet, könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ja, ich habe Lipuzet. L-I-P-R-U-Z. C-E-T.
Alles gut. Wie viel Milligramm?
Das steht 10 mg und 20 mg. Gibt es drin zwei Medikamente?
Warum steht es so, dass es zwei Nummern steht?
Ja, natürlich kann es sein. Ich kenne diese Medikamente nicht.
Aber ich denke, das ist eine Kombination von Medikamenten.
Okay. Ich nehme es gegen erhöhte Cholesterin.
Alles gut. Frau Blatz, haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich bin allergisch gegen braune Pflaste.
Braune Pflaste. Wie reagieren Sie gegen braune Pflaste?
Durch Juckreis und rote Haut.
Juckreis und rote Haut.
Graue Blatt, bitte.
Haben Sie geraucht oder rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol? Wenn ja, wie oft?
Ich trinke Alkohol, aber nicht so viel.
Vielleicht zwei, drei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Am Wochenende besonders.
Am Wochenende? Ja.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich diese Fragen.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen ausprobiert, oder?
Nein, ich habe nie probiert.
Und Ihre Eltern leben noch?
Mein Vater lebt noch, aber meine Mutter ist leider verstorben.
Mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck.
Vielleicht möchten Sie wissen.
Meine Mutter ist mit 89 Jahren an einem Schlaganfall gestorben.
Sie hatte Depressionen.
Sie hatte Schwermütigkeit. Ist das erblich?
Ich denke nein. Manche Seiten.
Es kann sein, aber das ist nicht der Fall.
Nur kann sein.
Danke Herr Dr. Es hat mich beruhigt.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Frau Lars, wo wollen Sie mit Filmen?
Auf der Hauptstrasse? Meinen Sie das?
Nein, nein.
Mit meinem Mann.
Aber zurzeit lebt er in einem anderen Zimmer.
Wegen meiner Probleme.
Wegen meiner Schnarchen.
Ich verstehe Sie. Es ist eine schwierige Situation.
Aber wir können eine Lösung finden.
Ich hoffe Herr Dr.
Sie haben Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Enkelkinder und zwei Töchter.
Zwei Enkelkinder und zwei Töchter.
Was machen Sie?
Ich habe lange als Krankenschwester gearbeitet.
Aber jetzt arbeite ich nicht.
Wegen dieses Problems Herr Dr.
Wenn ich alle diese Probleme lösen kann,
kann ich wahrscheinlich wieder arbeiten.
Sie sind auch unsere Kollegen.
Ich habe seit Jahren in Krankenhäusern gearbeitet.
Super. Alles gut.
Frau Blatzwita, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Nein Herr Dr.
Aber was denken Sie? Was habe ich?
Ich habe noch einen Verdacht auf Schlafapne-Syndrom.
Was ist das?
Schlafapne.
In der Nacht Atmung, Unterbrechung.
Bei mindestens 10 Sekunden oder so etwas.
Natürlich kommt es wieder, wieder, wieder.
Deswegen sind Sie beim Schlafen sehr unruhig.
Dann sollen Sie mindestens 2, 3, 4 Mal in der Nacht aufstehen.
Ich möchte als erstes eine Körperschung durchführen.
Dann ein paar Laborentzüge durchführen.
Dann eine Schlaflabe untersuchen.
Durchgeführt werden und so weiter.
Okay Herr Dr. Danke.
Bitte warten Sie.
Warten Sie ein bisschen.
Dann werde ich Ihnen 5 Arten sagen.
Okay. Ich warte auf die Interessierten.
Hör mal, ich bin so alt.
Beide haben sehr, sehr gut gemacht.
Als gestern.
Ich gratuliere euch.
Herr Öz, möchten Sie zuerst Ihre Vorstellung hören?
Ja.
Brauchen Sie ein paar Minuten?
Nein, ich möchte sofort weiterführen.
Dann Sarah Blau-Zwitter.
45 Jahre alt.
Jahrgipatientin.
Sie wiegt 85,3 Kilo und 1 Meter 63 groß.
Sie stellt sich heute bei uns seit vier Wochen bestehende Prognosen, Müdigkeit und Kopfschmerzen vor.
Sie berichtete täglich mindestens 8 Stunden im Bett, aber mindestens 2 oder 4 oder 5 Mal aufstehen musste.
Sie hatte seit vier Wochen schlechte Konzentrationsstörungen und Kopfschmerzen.
Sie ist sehr stark und hat eine sehr gute Schmerzintensität. Sie liegt bei 6 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Sie hat keine Auslöser.
Ihr Mann berichtete, sie ist sehr laut schnarcht. Sie berichtete auch, auf dem Rücken nicht schlafen könnte.
Sie warf täglich mit dem trockenen Mund auf.
Täglich müdig und schläfrig berichtet.
Sie musste beim Schlafen mindestens zwei Kissen benutzen.
Sie hat in den letzten drei Jahren ca. 20 Kilo zugenommen.
Beim Stuhlgang gibt es mehrere Jahre Verstopfung, Obstpassion und in der Nacht mindestens vier, fünf Mal Wasser lassen.
Kein Schmerzen. Ansonsten ist die Vegetativeanamnisse unauffällig.
Sie hat seit drei Jahren Hypertonik und vier Jahren Hyperkolesternemie.
Entschuldigung, ist die Patientin oder ist ihr Blutdruck gut eingestellt?
Leider habe ich diese Frage nicht gestellt.
Warum ist diese Frage wichtig bei diesem Fall?
Der Schlafhochdürfniszentrum hat immer eine Herzschmerzenprobleme.
Eine Herzschmerzen kann insuffizient sein.
Natürlich ist Hypertonik sehr wichtig bei diesem Fall.
Andererseits kann ein Bluthochdruck im Herzen eine Herzschmerzenverursachung haben.
Die Patienten beschreiben über eine Herzschmerzenverursachung.
Bei der Arztdifferenz kann man unkontrolliert über die Arterielle Hypertonie denken.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, diese Frage zu stellen.
Die Medikamente regelmäßig einnehmen, oder?
Viele Menschen nehmen die Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Trotzdem können sie unkontrollierte Arterielle Hypertonie haben.
Sie müssen auf die Ernährung nicht achten oder regelmäßig Sport treiben.
Deswegen sind diese Medikamente manchmal nicht ausreichend.
Deswegen müssen wir diese Fragen ersetzlich stellen.
Sie haben die Bluthochdürfnis gut eingestellt.
Ich hoffe, dass sie eine Krankenschwester ist.
Ich hoffe, dass sie die Medikamente regelmäßig einnehmen.
Ich glaube, dass es bei der Prüfung nicht so schlimm ist.
Sie müssen nur tonnen, damit sie nicht daran vergessen.
Danke für die Information.
Sie hatte vor zehn Jahren eine Gallenblaseentfernung wegen Stengel und Entstundung.
Das war komplikationlos.
Die Medikamente nehmen täglich 80 mg und Liposat 10 mg.
Liposat 10 mg?
Die Patientin sagte mir 10 und 20 mg.
Wissen Sie warum das Medikament so eine Dosis hat?
Das ist ein kombines Medikament.
Er lebt mit 6 und steht auf zwei Medikamenten.
Deswegen hat es zwei Dosis.
Es gibt zwei aktive Medikamente.
Deswegen sollen Sie beide dosieren?
Ja, beide dosieren.
Wie kann man sagen, dass 10 mg pro oder teilt ist?
Ich weiss es nicht genau. Ich habe immer gesagt, Liposat 10 mg und 20 mg.
Aber ich weiss nicht genau, wie genau das ist.
10 zu 20 oder 10 von 20. Ich weiss es nicht.
Okay, machen Sie keine Sorge. Ich schaue sofort. Sie können weitermachen.
Sie haben eine braune Pflaste Allergie. Sie reagieren auf Juckreis, Irrtem,
Hote Ausschlag, Pyrrhythes und Irrtem.
Nikotinkonsum wurde verneint.
Alkoholkonsum, 2 oder 3 Gläser Wein am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Vater leidet ein arterielles Hypertunium.
Mutter leidet ein Schlaganfall.
Sie ist verheiratet. Sie hat zwei Kinder.
Sie hat zwei Tochter und zwei Enkel.
Sie ist eine krankere Schwester.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Schlafapne.
Die diagnostischen Differenzen kommen Hypotreose und Anämie.
Obstruktiv Schlafapne-Syndrom ist eine Überatemwege, Verengung oder Verstopfung.
Es gibt eine Atemunterbrechung pro Stunde.
Sie haben sehr gut das Obstruktiv Schlafapne-Syndrom beschrieben.
Wofür spricht Schlafapne-Syndrom? Welche Symptome hat die Patientin?
Am Anfang schläflig, müde, konzentriert.
Sie hat eine Atemunterbrechung.
Kopfschmerzen.
Beim Schlafen?
Lautschnarchen.
Atemunterbrechung.
Bei der Anamnese ist es nur fremd.
Zum Beispiel ihren Mann.
Nektarine.
Super, Sie haben alle Symptome genannt. Nur Gewichtszunahme.
Ich würde gerne als Körper untersuchen, durchführen und dann ein Blutbild abnehmen.
Welche Werte würden Sie im Labor bestimmen lassen?
Ich möchte ein kleines Blutbild.
Was ist kleines Blutbild?
Kleines Blutbild ist ohne Differenz.
Es gibt nur Lekosid, Ertrosid, Lymphosid und Hematokrit.
Natürlich auch Brombozytose.
Blutbild ist mit vielen Differenzgruppen involviert.
Ich möchte noch eine Troide Schilddürse Enzyme.
Schilddürse Enzyme oder Hormone?
Hormone.
TSH.
Was? TSH?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich sage erst mal TSH.
FT3 und FT4.
Dann ein EKG verschreiben.
Sie können sagen, im Labor werde ich Blutbild.
Blutbild.
Ja.
Ich habe total vergessen.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber einfach zu sagen, sagen Sie erst einfach Laborwerte.
Blutbild, Enzyme, Parameter, Laborwerte, Elektrolytewerte.
Bei dieser Seite können Sie denken, welche andere Laborwerte möchte ich bestimmen lassen.
Ja.
Und dann würde ich gerne einen Schlaflaborterm vereinbaren.
Für die Patienten.
Was bedeutet Schlaflaboruntersuchung?
Ja, Schlaflaboruntersuchung ist eine moderne Untersuchungsmethode.
Die Patienten sollen eine Nacht schlafen.
Deswegen, damit die Patienten Schlafrhythmus, Herzpuls, Muskelaktivität und Schlafzeit recherchieren können.
Oder bestimmen können.
Eine moderne Untersuchungsmethode für die Diagnose Schlafapnezentrum.
Okay.
Und dann eine pulmonologische Konzil und eine psychiatrische Konzil vereinbaren.
Warum?
Die Frau Blasswita hat mitgeteilt, die Mutter hatte Schwiermütigkeit.
Schwiermut.
Ich denke, sie hat eine psychiatrische Problemhabe.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wenn Sie Depression als Differentialdiagnose nennen, können Sie natürlich eine psychiatrische Konzil anfordern.
Sie können natürlich eine psychiatrische Diagnose als Depression nennen.
Schlafprobleme, Gewichtsunahme, Obstipation, Konzentrationsstörungen, Immamütigkeit.
Diese Symptome gehören auf Depression.
Aber normalerweise sagen Sie, Sie haben nur eine Mie und Hypothrose als Differentialdiagnose äußert.
Deswegen brauchen Sie keine psychiatrischen Konzüren.
Das ist nicht falsch.
Ja, ich verstehe das sehr gut.
Außer Verdacht und Differentialdiagnose sind das ein bisschen gefährlich.
Sie haben viele, viele Fragen.
Alles gut.
Okay. Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Nach dem Schlaf-Labor-Untersuchung können wir ein SPAP-Gerät verschreiben.
Definitiv eine kreative Behandlung.
Was ist SPAP?
SPAP ist eine positive Erweichung.
Aus Englisch?
Ja, auf Deutsch.
Es ist ständig ein positiver Atmungsdruck.
Okay, super.
Wie arbeitet SPAP-Gerät?
Deswegen können die Namen dauerhaftige positive Atmungsdruck geben.
Um die Atemwege zu öffnen?
Um die Atemwege zu öffnen.
Dann wird der Schlaf noch ein bisschen ohne Aufwachen.
Ohne Atemunterbrechung zu bekommen.
Okay.
Das kann ich sagen.
Haben Sie ein paar Empfehlungen für diese Patienten?
Ja, natürlich. Sehr wichtig ist Lebensveränderung.
Gewicht reduzieren, Sport treiben, Diät organisieren.
Okay.
Vielen Dank, Herr Öz. Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Danke.
Ich habe 20 Minuten gesprochen.
Ich habe die Fragen von Ihnen schon ausgetauscht.
Die Fragen zum Schlaf, die ich mir vorstellen sollte.
Dann die Fragen zum Schmertz und dann die Atemnot.
Ich habe die 3 Gruppen.
Aber ich habe die meisten nicht vergessen.
Aber man muss die meisten nicht fragen.
Man muss die Patienten selbst sagen.
Man muss die Symptome nicht wieder fragen.
Man muss die Patienten nicht sagen, was sie sagen können.
Ich kann sie nicht so genau fragen.
Man muss die Patienten selbst sagen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Versuch. Ich möchte ein paar Dinge sehr ausdrücken.
Ich habe es mir sehr gefallen.
Dass ihr den Namen der Patientin in der Anfang oder in der Nachhinein ein paar Mal wiederholt habt,
ist sehr wichtig.
Sie wollen, dass wir die Namen der Patienten in Düsseldorf zumindest fünf Mal wiederholen.
Sie wollen, dass wir mit den Namen der Patienten mit ihr sprechen.
Das war sehr schön.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiger Trick.
Sie werden sich von einem Fehler machen.
Und ihr seid sehr sicher, dass ihr die Namen und die Zahlen habt.
Wenn ihr die Namen verpasst, dann hat der Patient es sich wiederholt.
Das ist ein sehr guter Weg.
Und dann ist es sehr schön, dass ihr Empathie zeigt.
Dass ihr die Patientin oft sagt, dass ihr in dieser Situation ein schwieriges Problem habt,
dass ihr ihr helfen könnt, dass ihr eine Lösung findet.
Das ist für viele Patienten so.
Man kann nicht verschiedene Sagen benutzen.
Aber es ist sehr wichtig.
Und das kann man auch nicht
als solches Wissen.
Aber heute sagt man, dass ihr eine Lösung findet,
dass ihr ein Problem findet.
Das ist für alle so.
Das kann Physiös sein, das ist belastend Physiös und das ist nicht einfach, um die Ankle kinder zu kümmern.
Das sind so Trick-Szenen, die man in ein paar verschiedenen Versionen machen kann.
Ihr habt das sehr gut gemacht.
Das habe ich gerade gesagt, aber das ist nicht so oft, aber es gibt einige, die der Patient selbst sagt.
Da muss man sich nicht wieder fragen.
Er hat etwas über den Luf-Not gesagt.
Dann habt ihr auch gesagt, ob ihr noch einen Luf-Not habt, auch Taks-Üba.
Das hat er in der Rede gesagt.
Da muss man sich nicht wieder fragen.
Er sagt, dass es eine Vakuum-Extraktion ist.
Er sagt, dass es ein Kind ist.
In solchen Fällen ist es nicht, dass man einen Kind hat, sondern, dass man einen Kind hat.
Ich weiß, dass es ein Kind ist.
Ihr habt es vorhin gesagt, aber es ist besser, zu fragen, wie viele Kinder es gibt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Er spricht von seinen Tohren.
Wir haben ihn gefragt, wie viele Kinder es gibt.
Das ist eine Scheiße.
Ich denke, es war sehr gut.
Danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.
In Teil 1, wir haben die Patientin nicht so gerne als Schlaf-Abne-Syndrom genannt.
Vielleicht ist es so in meinen Punkten, aber ich habe sie zu Beginn vorbereitet.
Dann hat sie sich immer wieder ausgetauscht.
In Teil 1, wenn wir die Patientin aufklaren,
oder wenn wir sie aufklaren,
sagen wir, dass sie eine Schlafbetzogene ist.
Das hat der Herr Chetin sehr gut gemacht.
Er hat uns gefragt, ob es eine Syndrom ist.
Sie hat uns gesagt, dass sie eine Schlafbetzogene ist.
Das ist eine Schlafbetzogene, die mit dem Schlafen zu tun ist.
Wenn wir das sagen, ist das eher menschlich.
Das macht es auch einfacher zu verstehen.
Schlafbetzogene, Atemstörungen.
In Teil 1, wenn wir die Patientin aufklaren, sagen wir so.
Aber in Teil 3 und Teil 2, also in der Dokumentation,
schreiben wir natürlich Obstuktiwes Schlaf-Abne-Syndrom.
Und wenn ihr die Patientin auf der Warte bereichet,
dann sagt ihr, ich sage das auch.
Aber ich weiß nicht das Notaufnahme-System.
Ich sage das, weil ich mich dann aufgewacht habe.
Das ist nicht so.
Und es ist auch gefährlich für einige Patienten.
Zum Beispiel in der Gastroenteritis.
Es gibt einen Risiko von Verbrechen.
Und in der Pneumonie gibt es einen Risiko von Verbrechen.
Wir senden diese Patienten nicht auf die Warte bereichet.
Ich habe in der Notaufnahme 3 Kilo-Situation gemacht,
aber sie senden keine Patienten dort.
Alle warten in ihrer eigenen Zimmer.
Sie warten in der Zimmer, in der sie sich beobachtet.
Anstatt auf die Warte bereichet zu warten,
kann man das so beobachten.
Das hat mir die Beobachtung gebracht.
Jetzt, was ist mit der Warte?
Herr Professor, wir haben die 2. Form schon wieder verwendet.
Ich habe sie am Morgen ausgedacht.
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Ich habe es tatsächlich gesehen, aber es ist nicht da.
Das ist die Warte.
Auf Schlaf-Besseugene hat man die Warte.
Hier ist es noch mehr zusammen.
Ich habe sie vor ein paar Tagen vor dem letzten Test
schnell auflesen lassen.
Es gibt natürlich noch Läden, aber es ist besser,
die beiden auf den gleichen Platz zu legen.
Ganz kurz, Herr Professor.
Es ist genug.
Es ist nichts anderes nötig.
Jetzt, was die Warte betrifft,
die Fragen, die wir hier haben,
die wir hier haben,
wenn es nur um Müdekeit geht,
wenn es nichts anderes sagt,
dann sage ich das so,
das tut mir leid,
dass sie so ein bisschen mit sich vertreten haben.
Um Empathie zu zeigen.
Müdekeit, Abgeschlecht, Leid,
das ist so nah, um zu zeigen,
was ich hier sagen würde.
Gibt es eine Warte,
die sie mit sich fühlt?
Ist es eine Grundlage,
um diese Worte zu fühlen?
Dann zeige ich die Worte.
F.B.
Feeleid habens isch Mertzsinn
oder habens isch Lafsch Törrungin
Warum so?
Die Grundlagen für die Abwechslung
sind, dass es eine Schmerzsinnung oder ein Schlafsinnung
gibt, um zu verhüllen.
Ich habe diese Frage auch bei Osas benutzt.
Ich habe diese Frage auch bei Chemotherapie
benutzt.
Ich habe diese Frage auch bei Medikamenten benutzt.
Manchmal kommt auch die SLE-Krise dazu.
Um nicht so etwas zu beantworten.
Um ihr Verständnis zu zeigen.
Und um weiterzulegen.
Können Sie das neu machen?
Ja, natürlich.
Es gibt immer eine Zeitung
in der man sich müde fühlt.
Zum Beispiel haben es vielleicht Schmerzsinn
oder Schlafschtörrung.
Wenn man dann eine Schreie hat
dann braucht es eine Schmerzsinnung.
Dann gibt es keine Sorge.
Die Schmerzsinnung ist nicht der erste der Zähne.
Wenn jemand es mir sagt,
dann叫 ich den Schmerzsinn.
Ich muss das erst mal ein bisschen ausprobieren.
Also, was der Sass mir sagt, muss ich das ausprobieren.
Morgan T. Koppschmarsch.
Aber Morgan T. Koppschmarsch,
da wir nur einen Sass haben, der Morgan T. Koppschmarsch hat,
braucht man nicht so viel Analyse.
Ein paar Fragen sind genug.
Und was kann Morgan T. Koppschmarsch machen?
Er kann wirklich Schlafprobleme machen.
Ekrem abe hat hier auch ein Schlafproblem.
Das ist ein Schlafproblem.
Er hat eine Urza-Kasse.
Und dann kommen die Fragen um das Schlafen.
Wenn man die Fragen an den Patienten notiert,
dann stellt man die Fragen an die, die er nicht sagt.
Ich sage zu dem Patienten, dass ich einen Schlafproblem habe.
Was ist das Schlafproblem?
Ich bin verabschiedet, aber...
Muss man hier Koppschmarsch nicht questionieren?
Wie bei der klassischen Schmarschanalyse,
wie bei der Morgano, Schittraler, V-Schittal,
ist es nicht möglich,
dann Schlafprobleme zu beantworten?
Nein, das kann sein.
Aber wenn Morgan T. Koppschmarsch
einen Schlafproblem hat,
dann stellt er die Frage.
Aber bei Morgan T. Koppschmarsch
gibt es nicht viele Fälle.
Deswegen ist es nicht notwendig,
wenn man Schmarsch-Fragen stellt.
Morgan T. Koppschmarsch sagt,
dass er Schmarsch nicht questioniert.
Schlafprobleme sind die Schlafprobleme,
die ein paar Stunden später ausgesucht werden.
Dann muss man die Frage stellen,
ob man die Schaffung beantworten kann.
Das ist nicht notwendig.
Es gibt keine Schaffungen,
die Schlafprobleme sind die Schaffungen.
Man muss sie nicht so viel questionieren.
Okay, danke.
Vielen Dank.
Dann kommen wir zum Schlafproblem.
Ich frage, ob man die Schaffungen beantworten kann.
Wenn man in einer Sitzung schlafen kann,
dann stellt man die Fragen
über seine Frau.
Das ist die Frage.
Wenn ihr Schlafprobleme beantworten könnt,
dann stellt man die Frage,
ob er Schnaarchen,
das Schlafproblem erlaubt.
Sondern wenn die Frau den Schlafproblem beantwortet,
dann stellt man die Frage,
wenn er Schlafproblem beantwortet.
Dann stellt man die Frage,
ob er Schlafproblem beantwortet.
Das ist die Frage,
und das zu beachten.
Ich habe das zumindest gemacht.
Dann
hat Art schon
vieles gesagt.
Er hat vieles gesagt.
Wenn er keine anderen
Anzeichen hat,
dann könnt ihr es fragen.
Denn die Situation ist jetzt klar.
Ob er mit dem Atem auf den Mund
schlafen kann, ob er morgens
mit dem Atem auf den Mund schlafen kann,
ob er oft in die Toilette geht,
ob er einen Kilo bekommt.
Das sind typische Symptome von Ossos.
Deswegen könnt ihr es hier fragen.
Aber hier könnt ihr es nicht unbedingt fragen.
Es kann auch in der Vagatative Anamnesi-Küste ausgehen.
Da könnt ihr es auch fragen.
Wir haben die Vagatative Anamnesi in vier Teilen geteilt.
Fiba,
Schützfroz, Nachschweiß, Kalsschweiß, Schweiß, Ausbrühe,
dann Apathit,
Gewicht,
Ferranderung, Schlaf.
Hier ist es schon nicht so,
dass man die Anamnesi-Küste nicht nachdenkt.
Dann
Bruce Schmerz,
Lufnod,
Herzrasen,
Engagefühl,
Gasrentest,
Übigkeit, Erdrehen,
Wasalasenprobleme,
Stuhlgangprobleme.
Hier ist es auch wichtig,
welche Differentiale
Anamnesi-Küste
oder Herzinsuffizienz-Küste
zu beantworten.
Hier gibt es ein paar Trick-Sorgen.
Was hat Ekrem hier gemacht?
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemägt?
Also eine wichtige Beine.
Fakette man das?
Warum hat er das gefragt?
Herzinsuffizienz.
Oder haben Sie Lufnod,
können Sie flachlegen,
zum schlafen oder
brauchen Sie ein Pakissen?
Warum?
Das sind die Fragen, die Herzinsuffizienz-Küste ausübt.
Das ist der Grund, warum Ekrem das gefragt hat.
Das ist die Differentiale Diagnose.
Oder Herzinsuffizienz.
Oder um Anämie zu fragen.
Das ist der Grund, warum Sie das gefragt haben.
Das sind die Fragen, die Sie hier gefragt haben.
Aber wenn Sie fragen,
haben Sie in letzter Zeit
Heufige Blutungen,
zum Beispiel Nazenblutungen,
Zanflaschenblutungen,
oder ist Ihre Haut
in letzter Zeit Blasegewurden
oder
Solgung ist,
können Sie das fragen.
Aber Sie müssen das fragen.
Es gibt nicht viel Zeit.
Es ist gut, wenn Sie das fragen.
Es gibt 10-15 Fragen.
Wenn Sie die Anamnesik-Küste fragen,
zeigen Sie, dass Sie aktiv sind.
Das sind die Fragen.
Die Reaktionen,
die Ekrem gemacht hat,
haben Sie gut gemacht.
Nur, wenn Sie mich auf die Angelegenheit
anregen,
wenn Sie sagen,
dass Sie eine Depression haben,
fragen Sie, ob Sie Erblicht haben.
Das werden Sie in vielen, vielen Fällen hören.
Sie fragen, ob Sie Erblicht haben,
wenn Sie Hypertension haben.
Sie fragen, ob Sie Gurunechter haben,
ob Sie Erblicht haben.
In vielen, vielen Fällen
können Sie solche Fragen stellen.
Ich habe das gesagt,
wenn Sie eine Angelegenheit haben,
dann fragen Sie, ob Sie Erblicht haben.
Ich habe Angst,
aber
ich habe zuerst gesagt,
dass ich Erblicht habe.
Dann habe ich gesagt,
dass es nicht 100% Erblicht ist.
Es gibt viele Fälle,
die ich mir vorgegeben habe,
wenn ich Erblicht habe.
Ich habe zuerst die Angst,
aber dann habe ich gesagt,
dass es nicht 100% Erblicht ist.
Es gibt andere Fälle,
die ich mir vorgegeben habe,
damit es nicht so schlecht geht.
Ich habe zuerst gesagt,
dass es nicht 100% Erblicht ist,
es gibt viele Fälle,
die ich mir vorgegeben habe,
wenn ich Erblicht habe.
Auch hier,
Das ist nicht unbedingt es gibt viele Fersche, die eine Ursache.
So weiter geht es.
Okay, ich glaube es gibt keine weitere Frage.
Reaktionen.
Wie gesagt, habe ich auch schon mit den Patienten gesagt, dass sie Schlafbett-Sogen und Atemstörungen haben.
Im Dokumentarverkauf und im Doktor-Doktor-Konzern habe ich gesagt, dass sie Obstruktur und Schlafapne-Sendung haben.
Ich habe auch Hypoteroze und Anämie als Differentialdiagnose genannt.
Ich kann sie auch mit anderen Krankheiten genannt haben.
Die Krankheiten, die wir als Differentialdiagnose genannt haben, müssen Sie auch gut wissen.
Sie können auch von dort aus nachfragen.
Um sie gut zu wissen, habe ich die Differentialdiagnose, die ich in anderen Krankheiten auch genutzen kann, verwendet.
Es kann eine Menge verschiedene Differentialdiagnose geben.
So.
Wenn Sie diese Fragen über den Vakuum haben, dann kann ich Ihnen alles, was Sie von meinem Übergang gelernt haben, in meiner eigenen Übergangszeit teilen.
Vielen Dank.
Okay.